When Ernest Cline's novel Ready Player One
came out in 2011, it was quickly dubbed the
"holy grail of pop culture" thanks to the
truck loads of pop culture references and
Easter eggs stuffed inside its pages.
The entire story is one big search for a literal
egg, so that should tell you something.
True to its roots, Steven Spielberg's film
is also a basketful.
Ready Player One is so full of pop culture
references that you'd be hard pressed to spot
them all with ten viewings, let alone just
one.
Here are all the Easter eggs we found in Ready
Player One.
Spoilers ahead, even if you've read the book.
Tomb of Horrors
The Ready Player One book made a big deal
out of Dungeons & Dragons imagery.
When Halliday tells the world about his Easter
egg challenge, he does so by mimicking the
cover of an old Advanced D&D Dungeon Master's
guidebook.
Other references come into play here and there
in the book's storyline, but the movie decided
to jettison most of them.
That said, there is still one very visual
Dungeons & Dragons reference in the movie.
In the later stages of the film, Wade meets
up with his OASIS buds in real life and spends
the rest of the time in Aech's converted mail
van.
On the back of the van is an image of a demon
figure with two horns.
D&D fans may have recognized it as a devil's
head seen in a module called "Tomb of Horrors."
Femme fatales
Calling out every single character cameo in
Ready Player One is an almost impossible task,
but we do have to give a shout out to the
ladies on the screen.
In the moments leading up to the massive battle
outside Castle Anorak you can see several
leading ladies charging into the fray.
Chun-Li from Street Fighter can be seen running
right beside Tracer from Overwatch, and behind
them you can just make out Lara Croft from
Tomb Raider.
Other heroine appearances include Ellen Ripley
from Aliens as well as Samus from the Metroid
series, who shows up as one of the dancers
in The Distracted Globe.
Even Zelda shows up during the final battle,
fighting right alongside Link and Ganondorf.
Serenity
The cult series Firefly enjoyed a second life
through the movie Serenity, and now Ready
Player One marks the second film appearance
of the series' iconic ship, Serenity — or,
at least some kind of Firefly class spaceship.
It first appears outside The Distracted Globe,
the dance club planet where Wade and Artemis
meet up.
The second appearance of Serenity comes closer
to the end of the film, when it soars out
over the battle and then Daito leaps from
its loading bay to join the war on Planet
Doom.
We still would have liked to see Captain Mal,
but we'll take what we can get.
Star tributes
Spielberg apparently spent years getting the
rights to use Star Wars characters in Ready
Player One, and after all that work, references
to the sci-fi juggernaut are still incredibly
hard to spot.
"So if you look very carefully you'll see
an R2-D2 somewhere, you'll see an X-wing somewhere."
But while Star Wars got a few character nods,
Star Trek got an entire scene recreation.
Well… more or less.
The scene in question appears when Halliday's
death is first announced and he releases his
Easter egg video to the world.
At the very beginning of that video, he's
seen lying in a coffin reminiscent of Spock's
coffin in Star Trek II: The Wrath of Khan.
The Starfleet insignia is even visible as
a flower wreath during the scene.
Sneaking it past Spielberg
Despite all the references to Spielberg's
films in the book, the director was keen to
leave those out of the Ready Player One movie
because he didn't want the whole thing to
become "too self-referential."
Aside from some Back to the Future gags and
the T-rex, there are no Spielberg-sanctioned
Spielberg Easter eggs in the movie.
But that didn't stop the production team — they
just had to get even more creative.
For example, somewhere in with all those characters
in the final OASIS battle, supposedly there's
one little Gremlin fighting in the mix.
"I didn't even notice the Gremlin until the
couple of times I had been working on the
effects shots, you know."
"After about four times seeing the same shot,
I said, 'Who snuck a Gremlin in this thing?'"
Zemeckis cube
Spielberg may have clamped down on references
to many of his films, but Back to the Future
sure got a lot of love in Ready Player One.
The DeLorean that Wade drives in the OASIS
is the most obvious example, and there was
this line:
"I'll wave to you from the finish line, McFly."
But there were several more obscure Easter
eggs from the franchise hidden throughout
the film.
Inside Aech's OASIS workshop, eagle-eyed viewers
can spot a hoverboard from Back to the Future
2.
But the best one has to go to the Zemeckis
Cube, the magical artifact Wade buys in the
mall after finding the first key.
The name, of course, is a reference to Robert
Zemeckis — who directed all three Back to
the Future films — but this Easter egg went
another layer deeper when it turned out that
the Zemeckis Cube had the power to turn back
time.
Jack Slater III
According to a theater marquee the cars pass
in the big race scene at the beginning of
the movie, Arnold Schwarzenegger is starring
in in a movie called Jack Slater III.
If that name sounds vaguely familiar, there's
a reason for it.
In the 1993 movie Last Action Hero, Arnold
Schwarzenegger stars as Jack Slater, a character
in a cheesy action film franchise that exists
only within that movie.
"You think you're funny, don't you?"
"I know I am, I'm the famous comedian, Arnold
Groundschweiger!"
"Schwarzenegger!"
"Gesundheit."
The movie playing at the beginning of The
Last Action Hero is — you guessed it — Jack
Slater III.
Meltdown
The Iron Giant was a fantastic addition to
Ready Player One.
His appearance alone isn't an Easter egg,
obviously, but he did get one good Easter
egg in.
After helping the crew reach Castle Anorak,
Aech and her Iron Giant fall down and sink
into a pool of lava…but just before the
metal man is gone for good, he gives them
all a thumbs up.
It's a recreation of the scene in Terminator
2: Judgement Day, where Arnie's T-800 shoots
John and Sarah Connor a thumbs up as he sinks
into a vat of molten metal.
Madballs
If you spent any amount of time alive in the
'80s, you probably had a Madball.
"Madbaaaalls!"
If you missed them the first time around,
Madballs were these rubber balls with monster
faces.
That was about it.
So don't worry — you didn't miss out on
much.
During one scene Artemis grabbed a living
Madball and used it as a grenade, but the
things were all over the rest of the movie,
too.
There's a detailed Madball painted on one
of the trailers in the Stacks, and this behind-the-scenes
article from Entertainment Weekly shows another
one painted on the walls of Artemis' rebellion
headquarters.
Weapon cameos
Madballs weren't the only weird weapons in
Ready Player One.
One of the items that Wade picks up in the
OASIS mall is the Holy Hand Grenade of Antioch,
which you may recognize from Monty Python
and the Holy Grail.
He later uses the Holy Hand Grenade during
the battle, although he doesn't even count
to three before throwing it.
"One, two, five…"
"Three, sir!"
"Three!"
There were plenty of other weapon cameos as
well.
For an instant, you can see a Star Trek Bat'leth
in one scene.
And in the ending battle, Wade whips out a
Halo rocket launcher, which he fires at the
Sixer army from his speeding DeLorean.
Deadite party
Army of Darkness's Deadites are everywhere
in the battle scenes of Ready Player One.
In the same scene with Chun-Li and Tracer,
you can spot a handful of them.
This clip of Halo Spartans charging into battle?
Yup, Deadites there, too.
Granted, they're probably an easy model to
use for filling out those massive battle shots.
Just repeat some sword-wielding skeletons
a few dozen times, and you have yourself an
army.
But in the movie universe, you have to wonder
why there would be so many Deadites.
Remember, each of those characters is ostensibly
a real person who chose that form to play
in the OASIS.
The only explanation is that people in the
future really love Ash and the Evil Dead.
And can you blame them?
"Groovy…"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!